how do you think about creating those
moments for your kids right in a world
where they can probably have everything
meet everyone have any experience they
want they're not going to be built on
the hard times and making it in America
every story I just told you isn't a
story about the struggle even though
they are they're a story about love the
love of my mom the love of my sister I
can replicate that for my children it
might be a fancier scene my son might
sit Courtside instead of last row but
it's still love what's going on
everybody welcome back to my social life
I'm your host Jacob Kelly today on the
podcast we are joined by Gary vaynerchuk
some of you know him as garyvee some of
you might know him as Gina no matter
what you know him as I'm very excited to
have him on the podcast today Gary
welcome to the show thank you for having
me I'm excited to have you what I want
to talk to you about today is a lot of
nostalgic things and so before we kind
of get into that I want you to
describes me what Nostalgia feels like
to you but I want to know about in a
very specific context I know every every
few years I don't know when the last
time you did this but you used to drive
by your childhood home and just kind of
soak in the Nostalgia yeah so when
you're staring at the car window at 53
Teaberry Drive I believe it was in a
Triplex the one on the left yeah um
what's that feeling when you're looking
at your childhood home I think Nostalgia
overall and then specifically when I go
to my childhood home and ironically you
brought that up because I haven't done
it a long time I've been thinking about
doing it recently and when I go garage
selling this spring to do a couple trash
talks I'm going to try to get to Edison
and look at the home
it makes you think about simpler better
times right like the reason you love
your Gremlin or your Spider-Man or your
house that you grew up in is it makes
you think of simpler better times it's
as simple as that uh at its best that's
what Nostalgia does
um or like it might even be simpler it's
just good times right it might it might
be high school might have been complex
but it was when you got your first kiss
and maybe like so it's just it invokes
emotion that makes you smile I've heard
you say that 82 to 88 89 is some of the
fondest years of your life so I kind of
want to stick in that pocket for this
interview
um I know you used to set up signs down
Oak Tree Road and tingly Lane for
Lemonade Stand I know you're used to
specifically set them at a certain
height so the drivers would see them I'm
curious what was actually on those signs
that attracted the drivers you know it
was very smartly intuitive about
marketing even as a young kid I remember
taking note when my mom would drive me
to the supermarket or just drive when I
would be in the car I would pay
attention to other people's lemonade
stand and garage sale signs looking out
the window and I quickly at like seven
or eight knew that like you couldn't
read them most the time items
I still take note of this by the way
so what the sign would say is it would
say 10 cents as big as you could imagine
like literally the entire sign was like
lemonade 10 cents and I would use black
marker like multiple times like I knew
how to make it thick and big and simple
and at eye level like and I didn't need
to put like what time it would be I
would take down a sign I didn't waste
that I just knew what I was doing and so
like it's wow that's a really fun
question for me because I haven't I
haven't answered anything about that
ever in my life so it's a great job on
you Jacob trying to bring out some
different stuff the signs on my lemonade
were very inspired by me this is me as a
theme I watched as a five and six and
seven year old it took note and then
when it was time for me to make my signs
I'm like I'm not gonna make those same
mistakes I'm going to be able to my
people are gonna be able to read it
and then I brought that skill to the
wine store
before we got a computer with a printer
we used to make the signs on the
displays by hand
and so when I was at the register
when there be downtime I would make the
sign regularly 8.99 on sale for 5.99 and
I remember like how different my signs
were when I first got to the liquor
store versus what my dad had like they
would take a regular Sharpie and put
5.99
mine would be like
three times the size of the sign the 599
was like bigger than the previous sign
itself like it was all that out I'm
curious another place that you kind of
look and watch and then replicate
yourself or do better on is with with
baseball cards I know you got into
baseball cards at John Adams Middle
School right in the Baseball Card Club
that's exactly right John Adams had a
baseball card Club I think I was our
science teacher I can't remember exactly
what the teacher was but it was a huge
huge thing for me
um sixth and seventh grade I I would say
sixth and seventh grade is when I became
like that's when you you know I talk a
lot about lemonade I talk a lot about
washing cars shoveling snow but that's
when there was a maturity to my my like
that was a step and that baseball card
Club was huge because
you know that's what that's what
communities and that's what a school can
really do is like brought people
together there's multiple kids in that
club that I didn't know from other
classes other grades and I very quickly
understood that I was like I remember
very quickly saying like I know more
than these guys I know more about
baseball I know more about I've
memorized the prices and the price guide
I
and then that's what I'm starting to
learn like oh I can talk my way into
like I could convince them to buy this
give me that card for this car that I
learned a lot during that era so when
you're at your first baseball card show
at The JCC on Oak Tree Road how do you
set your table up there versus how you
would set your table up now
you know I I don't vividly remember
the table design I remember vividly
pretty early and it gets a little blurry
right because this is 40 years ago but
like or or so like
um I remember quickly and I don't think
it was that show but I think quickly I
learned how I I definitely am always
watching
it's what I do for a living
so I remember I remember not knowing
what the [__] I was doing
and I remember knowing what I was doing
at the end of that weekend
so I came in super raw had no idea price
tag sticker I I don't I remember
actually now this is a fun interview
thank you for being so prepared
um I remember not having sticker pricing
on my cards
and I remember looking at the other
table like I only got price tags on
there like you know like I was like and
like like you know just like like this
is where like not being scared in
business like I just went to a dealer
and you remember these are like 40 or 30
year old men and I'm like 11. I'm like
can I get some stickers thank you like
you know like stickering my stuff
um it was you know I I re but but what
that all evolved to it back to the
liquor store I'm a merchandiser I think
about end caps I think about what
product goes at the register versus the
Shelf versus the first sign cap versus
what do you see when you first walk in
all of that I learned that baseball card
tables and shows and by year two by
eighth grade I had a meticulous plan of
like profit margin what I wanted to sell
I knew people bought from the middle not
the bottom and the top that I needed one
big thing to catch people's attention
because they would have a hundred tables
and they're just gonna walk by yours if
you just have display cases so I'd
always have something [__] crazy like
you know like I'd buy like a stuffed
animal and just put it on my table
anything to stop you from walking by and
that's that I recall so you learned a
lot from the lemonade stands you learned
a lot from the baseball card shows I'm
curious what you learned from the pig
farm because if I'm not mistaken your
dad bought a pig form when you're in the
eighth grade and you were shoveling pig
[__] your eighth grade summer yeah it
wasn't a pig farm it was my dad bought
like we moved to the woods and there was
a farm on like it wasn't like an active
Farm but it was like run down Farm stuff
and my dad you know this is 1989 so my
dad is only he's 36. and so he's and he
came to America so that's 89 and came to
America in 78. it's only 11 years
removed from him being in Russia in 1970
USSR like everybody had roosters and
pigs and you went to like the bazaar to
like like it was clean eating and old
school eating the stuff that's now
trendy and expensive like you know farm
to table for real real so he was into
that he thought that was cool I was like
this is the worst I like lost all my
friends we're in the middle of nowhere
and then he gets a pig and then he tells
me I have to clean up the pig [__] and
I'm like what the [__] that was like
real hard manual labor like every
[__] three days I'd have to go in
there to be a ton of hay it would all be
[__] infested I'd have like some
[__] boots on that were like fourth
generation Pass Downs I'd [__] rake
it once in a while like you'd go in and
like the [__] [__] would hit your lip
and I'd be like I'm eating [__] pig
[__] what is my life and like you know
and but these are all the things that I
look back on of like of course I outwork
everybody I [__] work my whole life
everything was work work work work
that's what my parents knew they still
good values and hard work and like
nothing that is going on with me is
confusing it was all built from the
scratch can you tell about your family
trip to Disney World that you took with
your mom and your sister me and my
sister and my mom my dad didn't go
because he was working took our first
family vacation in 85 86 I was like
fifth my sister was second grade
something like that this was like
us winning the lottery and getting a
private plane in a mansion and meeting
every select like going to Disney World
like you have to say McDonald's
was like
going to like Aspen for a month
for our immigrant family so for Disney
World we stayed in the Holiday Inn
my family didn't have credit cards back
then my mom ran out of cash by the third
day because the Disney tickets were more
expensive than she thought
she didn't eat for four days I eat like
a half a sandwich I remember playing
punch out in the arcade I remember being
scared to swim so I was like in the
kiddie pool with like two-year-olds
I remember it I remember singing Phil
Collins One More Night
the night before we went
and I remember it's like that's my
that's my crew right that's 82-89 it was
me my mom my sister AJ was AJ was born
in 87 so he he wasn't there for the
majority in him when he was he was one
and two my dad worked every minute I
barely saw him and so my life was my mom
and sister my childhood is my mom and
sister and that was the Crown Jewel
moment of our childhood we went
somewhere and first time I was on a
plane that I remembered obviously when I
immigrated I was on a plane but I didn't
recall and like it was just a big deal
and I'm just grateful for it like I
again I had dinner with my sister last
night
I had a really nice bottle of wine we
were in a fancy place here in Hudson
yards and I looked at the bill and I was
like this is more money than me and this
girl my sister who like were spent on
for eating out to dinner in our
childhood
like Red Lobster is only so expensive
and that was about as fancy as we got
during those times and so
it's really cool I'm really grateful for
my Hubble beginnings and I'm really
grateful for you to make this interview
be about those Early times I appreciate
that I'll ask you one last question now
we're about to see over time here how do
you think about creating those moments
for your kids right in a world where
they can probably have everything meet
everyone have any experience they want I
don't want them they're not going to be
built on the hard times and making it in
America
every story I just told you
isn't a story about the struggle
and the appreciation and the humility
even though they are they're a story
about love
the love of my mom the love of my sister
right the love we had for each other I
can replicate that for my children
it might be a fancier scene my son might
sit Courtside instead of last row but
it's still love
um and so I think that parents that go
through or people that go through
generational changes
if you I feel like too many of my
friends from that era that came up with
nothing hold on too much and try to
create fake environments for their kids
but you can't replicate it things change
but you can hold the True Values and
that's what I focus on I saw the head
now there is someone waiting for you
yeah they're here I'll let you go Gary
thank you very much thank you pleasure
real pleasure wish you well take care